so this is crazy you think this is
happening in a third world country but
no it's happening here in America
although we're on our way to becoming
a third world country
they are gonna start shutting of water
to citizens of Detroit because people
are behind on their payments because
obviously got a major
bad economic situation going on in
Detroit right now there is a hundred
eighty million dollar
dead the in the Detroit water and sewage
department that's what they have
so I every week they're gonna shut of
water supplies to 3,000 people
arch which will lead to about 250,000
people in total
we've got a little more info foreign so
nearly half above the 320,000 residents
who used the utility
are delinquent so they're just not
paying their bills anymore and Detroit's
average monthly water bill is nearly
double the national average a forty
dollars
and the Detroit City Council approved a
nine per cent hike last week so there
their increasing what the water cost is
the same time as they have this
tremendous amount a people that can't
afford it
a we gotta a quote from a member of the
the coalition charges operation we are
asking the UN Special Representative may
clear the US government that has
violated the human right to water if the
US government does not respond
appropriately this will also impact the
Universal Periodic Review
when they stand before the Human Rights
Council to have their human rights
record evaluated
that more bar lotion the national
chairperson the Catholic Canadians
obviously
Detroit Canada they're close to each
other so this is a board that's dealing
with these issues that they want the UN
to come in and help americans get water
I am so I guess the most basic
and being here is we need to just give
these people free water right like we
gotta suck it up and let our own
citizens have water
this Thursday country away at what is
going on that we're at a point where we
are questioning whether not
people water withholding yeah when a
Canadian waters he saw the council
millions Niagara water name lot amid
there's plenty greg has been okay so
somebody I was watching it and I'm sure
company
somebody's watching isn't going well you
know if these people can afford
their water then they don't deserve
their more seemed so what would you say
to those people had like this will go a
few days about water
and let me know how it works out for
them I this is not something that is
you know some some people can happily
out this is cable TV you're not paying
the cable bill we're gonna cut off the
cable is a something that they need it
to survive
this is a human right issue there are
people who are on life support
and homes connected to machines and it
is illegal
to cut off the electricity because they
need that to survive
people need water to survive and what is
the alternative peep they're gonna get
sick
gonna get dehydrated then I gotta go to
hospital ripped paper that what
where they gonna flush the toilet I mean
the sanitation was gonna throw the
streets like we used to
right I mean then there's gonna be
diseases in and this can be a problem
suspect everyone
highs even logical to want to take that
road it's gonna cost more money
the government not doing something
logical a camp a
alright so you're onto something there
because if you do shut off the water to
these people or the amount of disease
that's gonna
increase I mean it's a short term
financial answer to what will then lead
to a much bigger
socio-economic and health problem in all
that
your what we do its I i mean I think for
right now I think we have term
this is one of those issues that really
has to be taken and taken one day
one-week one-month the time because
we're talking about a minute so vital to
human survival
yeah and right now listen to trade you
can be used to getting you can afford
water
get Obama pay forget the government I
pay taxes
i'm happy to contribute to keep my
fellow brother and alive in my garden
pick my water bill to cuz
it is expensive you can I can if you are
have a low-wage job
80 bucks a month is a lot of money you
know I can afford it thankfully however
I can
understand that it is a struggle cuz
believe or not I was once
there where I was from gig to gig and
your bills
its it's hard to keep that all in check
at the end of every month
yeah I mean as a comic I know being
behind
yeah yeah arm how important you guys
think it is that we keep
Detroit going to remember during the
election they kept saying
biting kept saying bin Laden is dead and
GM is alive you know implying that
Detroit is a lie but now we keep hearing
about all this bad you need to rethink
his Canada
at maybe they want I don't think they'd
won it actually but but how important is
it that we keep
this Detroit going because it sorted it
seems to me that it's like the ground 0
lob what could really start spreading
across the country
if we shut off water to Detroit or we
don't help it come back economically
dollar that's a slippery slope man I'm
all for leave no man behind because then
what where we are going to annex
New Orleans Arena and we can start just
picking territories that we don't like
and get ready getting rid of them
its it's that I you know we are
americans take them in
I think you know rivers at my mind I'd
seen that was Mike this is why you host
the shower and I i dont
X would be if we want we welcome them
yeah I went and that now we're having a
janitor perpetrate may be an active
we should convince will be anything this
and I yeah where is the pride that comes
along with Nick
letting people part of our country i
mean that is part I'll our country
those are Americans yeah how can we
consider taking a waterway and why is
that the first thing that popped in
people's mind
they can pay their bill so we should
take away their water like maybe the
idea of creating job sir
are thinking of something that what
economically help the area grow like
that's not something that people
immediately think I have the first
thought that most people commented on
this was
cut it off if they can't pay it they can
expect me to pay it on their neighbor
and it's just like
really yeah looking such as social as
wanting water for everybody
100 by the way to represent it what
percentage of our bodies is water
like eighty or something eighty-year
something percentage of your body is
waters let's just give water
to people that can afford it we can do
that might write but I'm pretty sure
we could write it off no idea that
thousand at roughly 80 it's rather IAAF
pinkwater be wrong with Amber
is good for you